Our first story has
serious global implications,
the very survival of
the human species,
but it's about something
that really couldn't get
more personal--
fertility.
Researchers have recently found
staggering drops in male sperm
count in Western countries.
The big question is, why?
Correspondent Tim Samuels
agreed to put himself
on the front lines
in New York to figure
out what's up down there.
[music playing]
I'm Tim Samuels, in
New York, investigating
a crisis close to home--
the global spermaggedon.
[music playing]
An alarming new study has found
that between 1973 and 2011,
sperm counts in Western males--
men in North America, Europe,
Australia, and New Zealand--
dropped from an average of
99 million sperm per cubic
centimeter to just 47 million.
Theoretically, if
the trend persists,
by 2050, our sperm may
disappear entirely.
[music playing]
I'm here to add my sample
to the scientific pool,
and I am deeply hopeful that
mine are still swimming.
[music playing]
Hi.
I'm Tim.
Hi, Tim.
I'm Miriam.
Hi, Miriam.
TIM SAMUELS (VOICEOVER):
This is about to get awkward.
OK.
Here's your specimen jar.
You can come right on in here.
You're provided with the
materials that you need.
And once you're finished, you
give me a call at this number.
Is there a special word?
Thunderbirds are go?
MIRIAM: Uh, you're done.
OK
[chuckles]
OK?
Good?
- Yeah.
- I'll see you then.
See you on the other side.
MIRIAM: Bye bye.
Cheers.
[music playing]
TIM SAMUELS (VOICEOVER): With
Miriam analyzing my sample
upstairs, I'm turned
loose on the streets
to fret over my count and
the modern day phenomena
like stress and obesity
believed to lower it.
Don't get me wrong.
I take my fertility
very seriously.
To prep for this count,
I've been eating right,
exercising, managing stress.
Recently, I even started
laying off the booze.
But troubling research suggests
little of this may matter.
Of the many factors contributing
to sperm count decline,
there's one that's
especially hard to avoid--
plastics.
More specifically,
a group of chemicals
found in many plastic
products called phthalates.
Phthalates are added to
plastic during manufacture
to make it soft and flexible.
They're just wonderfully
versatile, amazing products.
It's just that they also
have the effect of altering
our bodies' hormones.
TIM SAMUELS (VOICEOVER):
Epidemiologist Shanna Swan,
who co-authored the
breakthrough fertility study,
also researches
phthalates' effect
on the hormone testosterone.
Shanna's met me at
this 99-cent store
to show me how ubiquitous
these chemicals are.
TIM SAMUELS: For me
handling a plastic bottle,
how does it get from
there to my testes?
The chemicals that
we were concerned about
are not chemically
bound to the plastic.
They are in the composition,
but they come out.
TIM SAMUELS (VOICEOVER):
Microwaving leftovers
in a plastic container
is a prime example.
When heated, the
phthalates leach out
of the plastic into the food.
We're ingesting them,
we're absorbing them,
and we're breathing them.
TIM SAMUELS (VOICEOVER): For
reasons not entirely known,
once inside the body,
phthalates seem to inhibit
testosterone production.
That's scary enough
when you're a grown man,
but Shanna's research
suggests worse damage could
be done before we're even born.
Your mother, when she was
pregnant with you, what she
drank, what she ate,
what she was exposed to
was actively affecting
your body within her body.
TIM SAMUELS (VOICEOVER): For
his sex organs to develop,
the male fetus needs
testosterone in utero.
[music playing]
When it's not there
at the right time,
in the right amount,
then he can be what we
call incompletely masculinized.
TIM SAMUELS (VOICEOVER):
Translation--
his testicles may not develop,
and his penis may be smaller.
SHANNA SWAN: And he will
have a low sperm count.
That's extraordinary.
SHANNA SWAN: It
is extraordinary.
[music playing]
TIM SAMUELS (VOICEOVER):
The fertility study
which Shanna co-authored
focused on Western men
because similar data is less
available in other countries,
but that doesn't mean the
phenomenon isn't worldwide.
If that trend
continues as is, does
it start to pose existential
threats to our species?
I am not a seer.
I can't predict the
future, but I can tell
you what doesn't look good.
[music playing]
TIM SAMUELS (VOICEOVER):
Our poor dwindling sperm.
They're working overtime to
propagate the human race,
but how much longer
can they keep up?
What would a post-sperm
world look like?
Looks like I picked the
wrong week to stop drinking.
Things are grim.
I wouldn't deny it, but I'm
a little bit more optimistic.
TIM SAMUELS (VOICEOVER):
Bioethicist Arthur Caplan
sees a future in which we
ditch concerns about raising
sperm counts and
focus on raising
actual sperm with stem cells.
It sounds a little nuts,
but you take the cell,
you put it in a dish, you put
the right chemicals around it,
and lo and behold, you can trick
it into making sperm cells.
TIM SAMUELS: So is the future
of reproduction in 20, 30 years,
you know, darling,
let's make a baby.
Rather than having
sex, hold on, I'm
just going to take
some stem cells,
reverse engineer them,
and try and select
the sperm from there.
I think sex always
will have a future,
but it may get disconnected
from reproduction.
Engineering a better
baby is the future.
[music playing]
TIM SAMUELS (VOICEOVER):
Sperm by design.
I'm ready to dive right in.
[music playing]
Engineered to have my
most desirable traits--
intelligence, stunning
good looks, athleticism,
ready to pair with
the perfect egg.
[music playing]
This technology
will be great when
it's ready in 10 or
15 years, but that
might be too late for me.
So I'm headed back
to Weill Cornell
to learn how my sample fared.
[music playing]
It's a bit like being an
expectant expectant father.
Tim, hi.
Peter Schlegel.
- Great.
So we're going to
go right in here.
TIM SAMUELS (VOICEOVER):
Weill Cornell
urologist Peter Schlegel
specializes in male fertility.
OK, so we've got some results.
Miriam is looking at
the sample right now.
[music playing]
OK, so that's-- that's
my, uh, my chaps in there?
That is your sample on there.
TIM SAMUELS (VOICEOVER):
Time for the moment of truth.
TIM SAMUELS: This is it?
Wow.
This is-- it's mind-blowing
to see your individual sperm.
Now, are they swimming
just erratically in circles
or is there a pattern to this?
Well, they never
ask for directions,
which is part of the problem.
Yeah.
TIM SAMUELS (VOICEOVER): But
now for the potent question,
how's my count?
PETER SCHLEGEL: The
concentration of sperm
in the sample is 87 million.
The average man will have
60 to 80 million sperms.
You're even a little
better than than average.
OK.
But is the assumption
that, had I
lived 40 years ago, if
we'd been doing this,
it would have been better?
Good question.
Probably in the
previous generation,
numbers were higher.
[music playing]
TIM SAMUELS (VOICEOVER): OK.
So thankfully, my
chaps can swim better
than I can, and
theoretically, seem
up to the reproductive task.
Now, just the small matter
of finding an egg they
can call home.
[music playing]